Donald Trump has done a ton of bragging
about how he has been doing so well in
the republican primary in spite of not
spending any money on campaign ads but
he is changing his tune on that Trump
told a rally earlier this week in Nashua
New Hampshire the site of the februari
ninth primary election that he is soon
going to begin spending big money
millions of dollars to win the early
primaries to date he appears to have
spent only a little over two hundred
thousand dollars on advertising compared
with for example 41 million dollars
spent by Jeb Bush and his allied super
PAC but Trump says that is changing that
starting on january fourth which is the
first Monday of 2016 he will be spending
a lot of money about 2 million dollars a
week on ads let's take a look at this
tweet that Donald Trump sent out my
campaign for president is 35 million
dollars under budget I have spent very
little and them in first place now I
will spend big in Iowa New Hampshire
South Carolina I welcome this hugely I
mean Trump will not be the Republican
nominee anything that extends this
fantasy world he has created in the
Republican Party is a good thing spend
four million a week for all for all I
care well inject some stimulus into uh
broadcast television yeah and and big
corporate media I you know whatever
everyone else is doing it and this money
is going to have probably no impact on
his uh you know on his accounts overall
the one is account i was gonna say is it
going to have any impact on the race
because we've we've hypothec up a little
we hypothesize that the Trump voter is
number one primarily a low information
voter and number two completely confused
about whether they're even conservative
because half the stuff Trump says are
ideas that are mostly heard on the
Democratic side in the Republican side
my sense is that by TV advertising Trump
is not really going to reach many more
people that would even consider
supporting him so I I'm curious as to
the marginal return that Trump might get
on this TV advertising maybe it will
move the needle Louis but I think Trump
is rapidly approaching if
not already at his sort of ceiling of
support yeah but it could move more of
the bush supporters over it could move
more of the Rubio supporters over uh if
they start realizing that it's between
Cruz and Trump you know the advertising
might help in that way a little bit but
is going to have a huge impact probably
not we will see i welcome the ads I
welcome the spending and early next week
we should get a look at some of these
first ads that Donald Trump will be
running